fret not because it does get easier over
time if you include these daily
practices
little by little it becomes easier and
it doesn't feel so monumental
and it actually simplifies your life so
much when you take
into consideration start living these
foundational simple principles in ways
that we're supposed to thrive
hey guys welcome to the ellen fisher
podcast today we're going to be getting
into part two of simplifying plant-based
nutrition and tips to thrive
in part one of the last episode we
covered a lot of different things we
talked about the overwhelming science
showing the benefits of eating whole
plant foods
and also the science showing the
increased risk of
cardiovascular diseases chronic
illnesses strokes high blood pressure
and autoimmune diseases for eating
a diet that is high in animal products i
also touched a little bit on our basics
of our biological design simple
understandings that have been suppressed
over time
for us since we were children which
really helps to just basically
understand
how we were designed to naturally thrive
i touched a little bit on
my healing journey and also got into
information about the blue zones and
some nutrition tips as well
but today we're going to be diving
deeper and exploring
more intimately about details on helping
you to thrive
on a plant-based diet long term
including
what foods you can eat and meal planning
and shopping lists and
how to center your plate possibly center
your plate if that's what works for you
and a little bit on supplements and i'm
also also going to go into
more depth about the blue zones and
other lifestyle factors that can help
promote longevity for us over time
because
health is so much more than just what
you eat and if you'd like to get even
more tips than i share in this episode
today you can get any of my ebooks at
ellenfischer.com
filled with beginner vegan tips health
tips and encouragement
all of our family's favorite recipes
that are both delicious and nourishing
tips for raising healthy plant-based
kids and more first
let's just cover the basics of if you're
new to this lifestyle
you might be wondering what do i eat
you've been eating
a standard american diet or different
kinds of diets with animal foods in them
for your entire life now how do i jump
into this lifestyle
i firstly want to mention that there is
no one way to eat plant-based even
within
whole foods plant-based eating there are
numerous ways to do it that's going to
help
you personally thrive so don't compare
yourself to other people
because it's going to vary a little bit
here and there depending on person to
person
and don't compare what you're eating to
someone on instagram
i'm on instagram you guys know me i
share a lot of what i'm eating get
inspired yes
but you do not need to compare or try to
copy and
make your foods look exactly like
someone else because what's available to
you in your location is going to be
way different than what's available to
me so if i'm eating a lot of bananas and
local coconuts that doesn't mean you
actually are gonna have access to those
foods or maybe the bananas at your store
are so crappy and not even worth getting
fret not you do not have to eat bananas
to be healthy there are lots of
different ways
to eat whole foods plant-based and
different types of fruits for instance
just within this one category that you
can be eating
also not to mention the foods that
someone else is eating may vary for
what's going to help
you feel your best it's going to be a
little bit different and we're all
individuals and while we have like a
broader understanding of what's going to
help us
as a species fill our best it doesn't
mean that there's not going to be little
variances here and there so you
definitely don't want to be comparing
yourself
to someone else and the foods that
people eat in different parts of the
world
can be completely different but both
whole foods and both balanced so that's
just something really important to
remember if you're in
a part of the world in asia or you're in
the um in the u.s or you're in europe
it's gonna be completely different based
on what's available to you and what's
gonna taste the best as well especially
fresh produce is going to be different
completely all right
something really important to address is
that one of the biggest mistakes that
people make when they're first trying to
go plant-based is not eating enough
calories and i know i mentioned this in
the first episode but it is very
important to mention
again it's super important to not only
take away the foods that you're used to
eating but to replace them
with other nutritious and calorically
dense plant foods
so for example if you're used to eating
a chicken salad
throughout your week and it has feta in
it and an oil-based dressing
you can't just take away the chicken
take away the feta and take away the oil
dressing replace it with this
low-calorie plant-based dressing
you have to replace it with nutritious
and calorically dense plant foods
to help you feel your best and to feel
satisfied not only for
nutrition the nutritious aspect but also
for the calories
so this is obviously just one example
but if you take away the chicken replace
it with some chickpeas which are high in
protein
and instead of the feta make some nice
creamy almond crub
crumble to place on top and instead of
the oil-based dressing
add some avocado for those healthy fats
to your salad this is just
one example of course i could also use
the same
response for like a black bean stew if
you're used to doing like a chicken
broth
or in your stews replace that with a
vegetable broth and then instead of
adding chicken make sure to add extra
beans to those
to your to your soup i don't know why i
said chicken twice but that's just what
came to mind for the first thing for me
another thing is to make sure that you
are centering your plate
in a holistic balanced way and maybe
this is going to be a little different
for some people but in general i have
found it over the years
super helpful that when you're creating
a meal
to have a balance of a carb rich food a
carb dominant food a protein rich food
and a fat rich food on your plate
for most meals that doesn't mean every
single meal because there's a lot of
times where i wake up in the morning
and i'm ready to eat something but i'm
not necessarily in
in the mood or desiring to eat a whole
big meal
and so i'll just start with like a mango
or start with some fresh fruit
or small smoothie for my day or even
some fresh juice
but when it comes to i'm ready to eat
like a meal that's going to satisfy me
and last me
multiple hours it's really helpful to
learn
what foods are rich in different
macronutrients so you can
make your plate accordingly so for
example
avocados coconuts nuts and seeds are
rich
in fats and hemp seeds even is rich in
protein and fat so if i'm going to make
a smoothie in the morning
and i'm ready for that to be my meal to
last me multiple hours i'm going to be
adding
at least a couple tablespoons of hemp
seeds into my smoothie maybe even some
plant milk to up those calories
um along with the fruits and vegetables
not just to have just fruits and
vegetables and
in the past uh throughout my journey
i've definitely had times where i only
did like the fresh fruits and vegetables
and over time i've just found it really
helpful to add
those hemp seeds or different seeds like
flax seeds and chia seeds to my
smoothies
because it's also not only more filling
but also
really nutritious to add those foods
into your smoothies as well
but you may not be into smoothies and
that is completely okay you do not have
to drink green smoothies
or any kind of smoothie to sustain on a
whole foods plant-based diet like i said
earlier
it all comes down to finding what works
for you and what's available to you
i live a very um
fast-paced lifestyle i am
very busy with the four kids and running
a business so a lot of times a smoothie
is just my easiest way to make sure i'm
getting my greens in
but also to just get those calories in
while i'm out about
and i'm on the go a lot of times we're
just heading out somewhere and that's
just the fastest thing for me
but there's other ways to eat really
fast meals as well especially in the
morning you can make
oatmeal and if you like oatmeal and
that's sustainable for you
make the oatmeal put some maple syrup in
it and some ground flax seeds or
different seeds as well fresh fruit on
top cinnamon
you name it back to talking about eating
until you're full and getting enough
calories i once had a friend who said
i tried eating vegan for a few days and
i just man i was just so tired and
hungry all the time
mind you this is like a pretty big dude
he's a big guy and i'm like
man why did you not talk to me about
this what did you eat i could have
helped you over these three days what
were you eating over those three days
he said i pretty much just ate a salad
for three days in a row for three
meals a day not even because he didn't
really go shopping he ended up just
taking the foods that he did have at his
house that was plant-based and wing it
he was like i'm just gonna not eat the
animal foods that are in my fridge
i'm just gonna eat whatever plant foods
i have and that for him was pretty much
just salads
i'm like you cannot just eat salads
three times a day that is not gonna be
like filling you up or being nutritious
for you because you're not going to be
able to get that wide variety of plant
foods
and make sure that you're getting enough
calories i cannot stress enough how
important it is to
get enough calories and eat until you're
totally satisfied
which is completely different than
almost every diet out there
most diets are restrictive in some form
or another because animal foods and
processed foods
are very high in calories so you have to
train your body to
not eat until you're totally satisfied
or as much as you want
most of the time for a lot of diets
because they're so calorie rich but when
you're eating a whole foods plant-based
diet
or a plant-predominant diet you're
eating a lot of foods that are naturally
low in calories and high in water and
fiber
so it takes some getting used to to eat
more bites of food than you used to
before and you know
what's really helpful to understand is
that when you're not eating enough
calories you're much more likely to
have a desire to lean towards foods that
are not as optimal or as healthy for you
simply because generally the foods that
are not as healthy for you
like processed foods tend to be really
quite high in calories
and your body is signaling to you that
you need more calories or possibly even
more nutrition
so if you're not eating a nutritious
diet that's rich in
vitamins and minerals minerals are so
important for you to fill your best
on top of the calories making sure
you're getting calorically rich foods
and eating until you're full you're more
likely to gravitate towards those foods
that are not as healthy for you so if
you get to the end of the day and you're
like
i'm consistently at the end of my
evening craving something sweet
that could mean that you're not getting
enough carbs in your diet and enough
sweet fruit in your diet
doesn't always mean that's the case and
it's totally normal to at the end of the
day you want to eat something sweet
sometimes here and there but if that's
like a consistent
um thing for you where you find yourself
even after dinner craving something
sweet and you're
you're still hungry even often after a
pretty good size portion dinner
that might mean that you're not eating
enough earlier in the day and to get on
top of eating more
and you know my dad eats plant-based now
after so many years you know he actually
started he ate like paleo back when i
first
went plant-based and at the time he was
like yeah i'm definitely going to be
eating my meat i'm not going to be
eating plant-based with you
but over the years something shifted and
it wasn't actually until just i think a
few years ago might be three years ago
now where he started eating more
plant-based
especially for him as a man it takes it
takes more getting used to to ensure
that you're eating enough calories
eating uh
um calorically rich foods but this is of
course for women as well
but just because men in general need
more calories that in the beginning he
wasn't eating enough and he kept feeling
lethargic and tired and that's truly a
symptom
not always but it can be a symptom of
not getting enough calories in your diet
once he started upping his calories i
came to his house and i showed him
looked at
this meal that you're making for
breakfast is just not sufficient it's
about half the size that you need
you need to be doubling this cereal bowl
that you're eating with granola
double it in size add some fresh fruit
onto it as well add more the granola on
top
maybe even have a smoothie on the side
and he's like oh okay
i get it now and suddenly he realized
how to eat in a way that's going to help
him
feel sustained and feel have great
energy
consistently throughout the whole day
all right i want to talk a little bit
about
going shopping and shopping lifts meal
planning some people find it really
helpful
to meal plan out those two weeks for
what they're getting going shopping for
and other people um kind of have more of
a
routine and a plan to just have their
consistent staple foods that they're
going to want to always have in their
kitchen at all times
because there's certain foods that's
just going to be really convenient and
easy for you to make something in a
pinch when you don't know
where you're going to head next what
you're going to make next you don't want
to have to plan
like these amazing dinners every night
and sometimes you just want to open the
cupboard and know okay i see the whole
wheat pasta or the brown rice pasta
i see the tomato sauce okay i got some
beans here
let's put that together and make a meal
so for us that looks a lot like
tomato sauces and pastas like dried
dried goods that can last a long time so
rolled oats as well as dried beans we do
a lot of dried beans and dried beans are
so much more affordable than buying
canned beans
they're actually the cheapest foods on
the planet dried beans and whole grains
a lot of people think that eating vegan
can be super expensive and it can it
really depends on how you're eating if
you're eating a lot of highly processed
vegan foods
um and not very many whole grains and
beans it can get quite expensive and
also
depending on your location how expensive
fruits and vegetables are to you
but if you're centering around the
staples of your diet eating
whole grains beans and tubers you're
going to have a much easier time
eating this way that's sustainable price
wise for you as well and also just when
you're
at the house to have that on hand and
know that you could whip up some sweet
potato fries or potato fries
to dip in guacamole in a pinch or to
make some pasta
or a bean chili based on having tomato
sauces and beans
on hand so i actually have done youtube
videos about this i have like um
go shopping with us like planning
uh what's it called food planning list
ahead and you can check that out on my
youtube channel youtube channel i'll put
that down
below on my regular youtube channel
ellen fisher
but there's so many different ways that
you can plan ahead and make sure you're
getting your staples so write out the
list of all the stuff that you
definitely want to have on hand
not just dried goods but also fresh
fruits and vegetables so you
you're gonna find over time what fruits
and vegetables you most gravitate
towards
so for us that could mean like broccoli
and cauliflower and we love bell pepper
and those non-sweet fruits like bell
pepper and cucumber
we love carrots we use carrots in a lot
of different things
and so on but we also find it really
helpful to branch out
and try new foods every week we like to
see whatever
new food that we can add specifically
fruits and vegetables to our diets and
that might be a different kind of bean
so like normally we'll be buying like
kidney beans or black
beans but for our stews last week we
decided to buy those white northern
beans and try it in our soups and it was
super delicious
if you're shopping at the farmers
markets you can get what's local and
available to you
or if you're not able to go to farmers
markets and you're getting a regular
grocery store
look for what fruits are on sale because
generally those are what's uh best
in in season that they're ripening
really well and also it's more
affordable
so for us at certain times of the year
where blueberries that are imported here
are a great price where there's other
times of the year where the blueberries
are like eight dollars
for a little carton and we're definitely
not buying the blueberries at that time
of year
but when they're on sale when they're in
season and it's like four dollars for
two cartons of blueberries
that are organic we definitely go for
those we'll eat a whole bunch of them my
kids
love the berries and speaking of kids i
need to do a whole episode or
multiple episodes on child nutrition
that's definitely going to be happening
over time
some other great staple foods is
sourdough bread
we love whole wheat sourdough bread my
kids love avocado toast and
it's a great way to get like a great
snack in or
to pair the avocado toast with some
beans
and fruit on the side but i find whole
wheat sourdough bread to have that on
hand is a great
a great food to have unless if you're
eating gluten-free then you can get
gluten-free bread or gluten-free
tortillas
but corn tortillas gluten-free tortillas
those are great things to had
to have on hand as well or whole-wheat
tortillas depending on how you're eating
it can also be helpful to find certain
recipes online that you are inspired to
create that week and then base your
grocery list off of that
don't overwhelm yourself and think
you're gonna make a brand new dish
seven days a week every single week
that's just way too overwhelming
i think sticking with like a new recipe
once a week or twice a week
is sustainable at least for us what we
like to do
and also don't get stuck in the same
cuisine branch out there are so many
amazing plant-based foods that taste so
delicious that i would have never
considered before i was vegan
i never used to eat lentil doll before i
was vegan and now i realize that you can
make lentils so creamy and they taste so
good and actually the beginning of my
like plant-based journey i never really
ate that many beans and then over time
i really developed a desire to eat them
and feel really good on them and my kids
love them as well
my kids have always loved the beans
though since they were little but lentil
doll
going off on a tangent there lentil doll
choosing all different kinds of indian
cuisines
asian cuisines and not just sticking
with like american or pasta
is a great way for you to get exciting
your palette
and or to excite your palette and to
really start enjoying plant-based foods
in a whole new way
it can be fun to take your favorite
traditional foods and
turn them into a vegan dish and you can
honestly find that
anywhere online type in i want to make
vegan nachos how do i make vegan nachos
which by the way
my ebook epic vegan cravings has the
most amazing nachos recipe you have to
get your hands on and it's healthy too
and that's one of my favorite parts
about my ebooks is because i love
turning
traditional foods that you love into
plant-based foods that are
not only vegan but also nutritious so
gotta try those nachos yeah so
definitely don't be afraid to turn your
favorite foods into
a vegan version and that's whole food
focused it might not be totally whole
foods or maybe you can find a super
whole foods version
of the way that the meal you ate before
but also
like i said don't get stuck in the same
meals that you always ate because the
possibilities
are endless pad thais and creamy lentil
soups and
all different kinds of things that you
never really ate before you were
plant-based
can turn into some delicious meals for
you okay i also want to talk a little
bit about the difference between
what is processed foods whole foods but
there's also something in between that's
like minimally processed foods
and we definitely like to get those
foods in our diet and it's helpful to
understand the difference to know that
like
this does not mean that like everything
you bring home from the grocery store
has to be just like just the fruits and
vegetables and the beans
that is like definitely like the staple
of our diet you know the whole grains
and all that and fresh fruits and
vegetables but
we love to complement our dishes with
convenient foods that are minimally
processed so
an example of a mentally processed food
is something that it has whole foods as
the source of what you're eating but it
might be turned into something different
than just being completely whole foods
and it has minimal ingredients
so a good example for that would be
pasta whole wheat pasta brown rice pasta
chickpea pasta quinoa pasta when you
look at the ingredients generally
there's only one to three ingredients
and
they're all whole plant food ingredients
and so we love to stock up on the pastas
another example is salsas and tomato
sauces we love to add salsas to our
mexican dishes
and tomato sauces in our soups and our
pastas and
really enchilada sauces all different
kinds of dishes so we definitely always
have that on hand
other examples of minimally processed
foods that are great additions to your
diet is like corn tortillas or
whole wheat tortillas just check the
ingredients because sometimes corn
tortillas can have
a lot of added ingredients that are not
great for your health versus you can
find tortillas that are
100 organic corn it also depends on your
budget and if you have a really tight
budget and the best you can do
is the corn tortillas that are in bulk
that have some added ingredients as
opposed to getting those
those awesome little small packages with
100 organic corn like just do the best
you can and get those other tortillas
because it's all about a journey and a
transition and whatever time and life
phase that you're in
do not beat yourself up about not being
perfect um
that is one of the reasons why i love
this lifestyle so much because there's
such an emphasis
on food freedom and finding a way to
work out this diet that works for you
there does not need to be like these
strict hard and fast rules
that's never going to sustain you and
work out long term the goal is for you
to
move freely through your day without
having to spend so much energy and time
and mental energy on the foods that
you're eating now in the beginning
you might have a transition phase
especially if you're not used to cooking
it might take a little bit of effort to
find out
what foods make you feel your best and
what foods you like the best you know
especially if you're transitioning from
your taste buds
and just know that you can make whatever
dish you want you could make the most
amazing creamy pasta that takes two
hours to make and believe me we do make
those kind of dishes every once in a
while
because i'll get this like amazing
hankering for like a creamy pasta
that man just like satisfies me to my
soul because i'm all about creamy pastas
or you can make the most simple meal
that you can have for your heart's
desire so you could just pop a sweet
potato in the oven just fork it before
you pop it in the oven let it bake for
an hour
and then after it's cooked and it's soft
you open it up top with some canned
black beans
some avocado and salsa and you have
yourself a nutritious meal
and i think a good way to to have like
balance is to especially depending on
what you enjoy if you like those
decadent meals but you just don't have
the time as like a parent
to make the the most decadent meals all
the time just find a balance to do a lot
of really simple meals throughout the
day in the week and then maybe once or
twice a week you dabble in like a super
amazing dish that takes a little while
and takes a little bit of creativity
to create and follow a recipe for
so some important factors that we had
already eat more bites of food than you
did when you're eating an animal foods
based diet
that could mean adding more food to your
plate than you did prior
and also make sure to eat till you're
totally satisfied
once you get to that rhythm of
understanding intuitively how much you
need to eat
and eating until you're full starting
when you're hungry eat when you're
hungry and stop when you're full this is
something that we have been conditioned
to not do from a very young age
most of us a lot of us when raised on a
standard american diet
or a diet that's rich in animal foods
but once you start eating a whole foods
plant-based diet
it's very easy over time to learn to eat
when you're hungry and stopping
when you're full and for you this could
mean that you want to eat more often you
might want to eat four or five times a
day or you might
prefer three big meals a day i like to
eat about four times a day sometimes
five sometimes three it just depends on
my mood and how hungry i am that day
or how how big of meals i'm eating so
don't feel like you have to get stuck
into one place where you have to only
eat a certain number of meals a day
just eat when you're hungry and over
time you will find a rhythm
that is naturally intuitive for you that
helps you feel your best
another thing we covered was to eat a
wide variety of foods and to try new
foods this doesn't mean that you have to
get so crazy in the kitchen where you
have all these new herbs that you don't
know what to do with
but to incorporate one or two new fruits
and vegetables
into your diet every single week as best
as you can
also to build your plate on the staple
high calorie foods that are going to be
the most satisfactory and also super
nutritious for you so that would be
whole grains
tubers beans as the main sources of your
food and also high calorie fruits if you
have access to some really good high
calorie fruits like we do here we love
to eat a lot of fruit in our diet
and that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's how much that you're going to
want to eat
but over time you will find what you're
going to gravitate to that's going to
help you feel your best and that's the
beauty of eating abundantly like that
another thing we touched on was to get
creative in the kitchen and don't
feel like you have to stay in this rut
eating the same kind of cuisine
there are so many amazing plant-based
meals that you can eat of all different
kinds of cuisines that are so satisfying
and super delicious and super good for
you so i next want to touch on
supplements first and foremost let me be
clear i am not an expert
i highly recommend that you take the
advice of your healthcare professional
and do not just take my word for it in
fact don't take my word for anything
that i'm saying
research and look up and contemplate and
consider
other experts well i don't consider
myself an expert just an expert of
experience but look up experts when it
comes to supplements of
course um something really important
about this
is that there's a lot of diets out there
that say
that we're not about supplements and and
we eat in a way that doesn't need
supplements but then when it comes down
to it they're like actually wait you
need this supplement
and this supplement and this supplement
and it's just a little bit contradictory
there's also ways of eating that just
really full-on promote all kinds of
supplements that just fill up the
cabinet
and that is not the way the whole foods
plant-based eating promotes
what's amazing is that food should be
the majority mass majority of your
nutrition
but that doesn't mean that you can't
enjoy or include some supplements in
your diet that's going to be super
beneficial for you specifically b12 if
you're eating a plant-based diet b12 is
definitely something
that you need to be taking this doesn't
necessarily mean that you need to take
it right when you go plant-based as
stores can last up a while but look into
and find the right b12 for you
especially over time b12 comes from
bacteria
and it's surprisingly that a lot of
people don't realize it doesn't come
from animal foods animals
get it from the soil actually a lot of
factory farms
and a lot of animal agriculture is
injecting b12 into the animals because
it's just not there anymore
because the soil is just not as nutrient
dense as it used to be
we also as a species used to get b12
from the water that we drink and
from soil on our foods without watching
it but we don't live like that anymore
and the water
is just not as clean and good as
it used to be so bta a b12 supplement is
super
integral on a plant-based diet you
definitely don't want to miss out on
that
some doctors and experts recommend an
omega-3 supplement
our family doesn't take it but you're
going to need to find out whether you
should take it or not it really depends
on family to family whether they
feel they need to take it based on their
healthcare perspective professionals
we eat a lot of wonderful omega-rich
omega-3 rich plants
and there's a lot of understanding that
the debate and the importance of
omega-3s isn't so much that you need to
severely increase your omega omega-3s
it's that if you're eating a diet that's
naturally low in omega-6 and you also
include omega-3s in your diet you're
going to have a healthy balance of the
three to six ratio because the ratio
that is the most important
so if you're eating a diet that's
naturally low in omega-6s
so you're not eating a lot of those
processed oils or
other kinds of foods that are rich in
omega-6 but then you are including
omega-3
seeds in your diet like hemp seeds
flaxseeds and chia
that's a great way to get your omega
omega-3s but there are
plant-based doctors that i see that
recommend to supplement that for all
plant-based
people so you're going to have to figure
out and find out what is the best for
you and your family
body grass juice powder is one of my
favorite favorite green powders to take
it is a rich source in vitamin a and k
it's very high potency
it also is an excellent source of iron
and manganese and
is a good source of chromium and
magnesium and contains trace amounts of
phosphorus zinc copper and calcium as
well
we love brownie grass juice powder
because it's a whole food based
minimally processed and it's a great
addition to an already whole foods
plant-based diet especially
for if you're not getting 100 of your
plant foods from
super dense soil that you know to be
super nutritious
it's just a great extra added thing to
to your diet that i have found
very helpful in my diet and my lifestyle
and it's definitely my favorite the um
barley graffiti powder that we take
is dailygreenboost.com i know the owner
there he's very
very meticulous in the process and it's
just a wonderful
wonderful supplement by the grass juice
powder other than those three
supplements
uh possibly omega-3 if you need that
definitely be 12 and possibly a barley
grass juice powder or a green and
nutrient-dense green powder
the rest is up to depending on how
important and well planned
and diverse diverse your diet is for
instance like selenium you can eat a
brazil nut
throughout your week eat brazil nuts
here and there as opposed to taking a
selenium supplement and if you're doing
a good job at
helping the bio diversity and the
bioavailability
of your foods to ensure adequate zinc
absorption and iron absorption you can
get that through your food
but it really depends on how well
planned your diet
is and if you're eating a wide variety
and a wide range of whole plant foods
specifically if you're getting organic
and getting some farmers bucket produce
as well you really should not be having
a problem with getting
all of those nutrients met specifically
and especially if you're eating enough
calories because the more bites of food
that you're eating the more nutrients
you're getting into your body
specifically from whole plant foods um
another one is sea vegetables we love to
eat sea vegetables specifically dulse is
where we get our iodine
we love to eat those throughout the week
in our salads and we put it on curries
as well
so i highly recommend getting some sea
vegetables into your diet you could go
with akame
or nori but nori is not as high in
iodine as the other
sea vegetables so just keep that in mind
all right now i really want to talk
about how health is
so much more than food you could be
completely focused on your
on the food that you're putting in your
body but missing all the other really
important
factors that create strong health
markers and feeling your best
because if you're not getting enough
sleep but you're eating all the adequate
food
like the lack of sleep is going to cause
just as much health problems
as just not eating nutritionally all of
it matters and i think a really good way
that we can look into
what's going to help us thrive and have
promote longevity is to look at the blue
zones like i've talked about before
they're very actually obvious and
makes so much sense but when it's laid
out like this especially in a world
where we have been taught to be so
fast-paced
it can be very helpful to remind
ourselves adequate sleep is integral for
long-term health
seven to eight hours is generally what's
recommended and
you breastfeeding mothers out there
breastfeeding at night i completely
fill you because it's completely out of
your control at that point and phase in
your life
to get deep sleep without interruption
i saw this one meme once that was like
what is your deepest fantasy that like a
partner is asking
asking a girl what's your deepest
fantasy and it says eight to ten hours
of uninterrupted sleep and
oh man that is definitely one of the
best fantasies for a mother with young
children
for sure so what i say for this is just
do the best you can know that it's a
phase of life
um that will not be forever and create
other
habits around your life that can help
you to ensure deep sleep and to be able
to fall back asleep when your baby wakes
you up
and so that you're not laying there in
the middle of the night things like
making sure you're eating enough
calories and
eating enough for dinner so you're not
going to bed on an empty stomach
that doesn't mean you necessarily have
to be on a full stomach but to be able
to have
not an empty stomach i think helps to be
able to
fall asleep easily and stay asleep to
eat nutritionally as well
and not having like blue lights and a
lot of screens around you
before bed so and then also just going
to bed
earlier i know it's tough because you
don't get alone time really throughout
the day and that's your one time to
really be alone
but i try to find a balance and have a
balance where i get some alone time
after my kids go to bed but i also don't
like
overdo it and stay up past a reasonable
time so i get that hour
or so with my partner and then i head to
bed 9 30 or 10
i'm in bed and i'm falling asleep
because i know i'm going to get woken up
multiple times throughout the night
um and if you're not a breastfeeding
mother and you're listening to this
take it take the other factors into
account as well to make sure you're
getting deep sleep
something that really helps you to get
deep sleep throughout your week is to
move your body throughout the week and
be
active this doesn't mean you need to
work out vigorously for six to seven
days a week
not at all it could be as simple as two
to three days a week moving your body
for
30 to 40 minutes a day and trying to
walk more places
if that's available to you and you live
in a place where you could walk more
areas
i feel my best working out three to four
times a week but these days with how
busy i am
sometimes two times a week is all that
happens i personally love high intensity
workouts and
weighted lunges and weighted workouts
but find one exercise you love that
you'll look forward to every single week
regularly exercising has so many
benefits and supports your health on so
many levels it supports your metabolism
it helps tone muscle tone it helps you
fall asleep and
stay asleep at night and so much more i
found that moving your body in a
consistent manner so it's part of your
lifestyle really helps you to have good
deep sleep the last thing i want to
touch on is sunshine
getting in the sun is so important we've
moved from
these largely outdoor creatures to
largely indoor creatures in a matter of
a century
and sunshine is so essential for health
it's one of the most amazing
things for your body and it doesn't mean
that you need to overdo it there's
obviously a balance in
everything if you ever do anything it's
not good for you but
uh the sun is the happy vitamin your
vitamin d
and i find a lot of benefit from making
sure i'm getting adequate sunshine which
also i think helps with sleep is to get
sun during the day
and that's actually a supplement i
forgot to touch on some people will need
to supplement
especially if you live in harsh winters
or have strong seasons or simply just
don't get adequate sunshine
we are supposed to be getting our
vitamin d from the sun
but that's simply not possible for a lot
of people these days especially being
just largely indoor societies the way
that we've turned into
so speak to your health care provider
and get your levels checked and go from
there
researchers found the lifestyles of all
the blue zone area residents share nine
specific characteristics and i just want
to read them off you can check this out
on like the blue zone study online as
well it's super fascinating
they move naturally they know their
purpose
they downshift meaning that the world's
longest living people have routines that
shed the stress
it's also i think really helpful to
understand that if you're eating an
adequate and nutritionally rich diet
and living in a way that's going to help
you manage that stress so that
it's it can handle it very well because
honestly you're never going to shed your
stress completely especially in the
world that we live in today
but taking both into account by living
in a way that's super
nutritious for you as well as
following habits that can help you shed
stress i think is a good balance
um the next one is that they have the 80
rule they actually
don't eat until they're completely full
they eat about 80 and then they end up
finding themselves
filling full 10 to 20 minutes after that
they have a plant slant meaning that the
majority of the blue zones consume only
small amounts of meat on rare occasions
and all of them eat a rich array of
fresh fruits and vegetables which are
packed with disease fighting nutrients
that i talked about in the last episode
number six is that they have wine at
five and number seven
is that they have what they call a right
tribe
the world's longest living people on the
earth are either born into or choose to
create social circles that support
healthy behaviors
the acarians enjoy tight-knit
communities that socialize frequently
while the okinawans build
what's called moai group of friends that
commit to each other for life
number eight is that they have belonging
and the ninth one
is that they have loved ones first they
care about their loved ones as
um for the rest of their lives and i
think part of that it goes into taking
care of your parents
and them not you know not putting them
in like a retirement home but spending
time with them in their old age which is
really helpful for them to be near
family and i'm not going to talk about
all these but i do want to touch on a
few of them
the first one being stress lowering your
stress is so
important but let's provide proper
nutrition and sleep so that your body
can handle the stress
well the the quality of sleep that you
get is super important
but also the amount of stress in your
life is going to have
a huge impact for me i feel like i have
kind of a high stress
life in my at least in the phase of life
that i'm in but i try my best to
minimize it where i can and make sure to
take like days off
when it could be easy to just keep going
with my job there's really like a never
ending list i never just finished the
check
off list it's never like okay done now i
can just you know take a week off or
whatever
i have to actively choose to de-stress
in that way and tell myself that
work the rest of work can i can get to
it a little bit later later
because stress having too much stress
leads to chronic inflammation which is
associated with every major
age related illness it's super important
not to live like a super super high
stress lifestyle
and if you are one of those people that
has a job that's very high stress i mean
that's essential
like an ambulance worker um or a
firefighter
like seriously mad props to you for all
the work that you do to help
um people in the world hopefully it's
not something that you have to do your
entire life and that you can
find ways to um live a less stress
a lower stress lifestyle at certain
parts in your life
another one i want to talk about is
purpose
some studies show that like i think it
said that only 30 of people find their
job to bring them a lot of purpose and
the rest of people do their job just
because
it's the way to make an income for
themselves and their family
but you can find purpose in other ways
if your job doesn't bring you a lot of
purpose
i find immense purpose in raising my
children and the relationships that i
have
but i also i am one of those people that
finds a lot of purpose in my job it
really
um just like i thrive on it i thrive on
just the next thing that i'm going to be
doing
and i love to make an impact i love
all the messages that you guys send me
and it really does give me a lot of
purpose
and really purpose can come from so many
different places and whether it's your
job or your relationships
or your faith or so many different
things within your life
that i think it's just really important
to make sure that that's something that
is a priority for you
if you're doing a job that you hate and
you are struggling going through life
without having much purpose in your life
i hope that you can find ways to take
action and have victor mentality to
completely shift your life so that
purpose
and passion and drive and
feeling um like so much gratitude and
satisfaction in the things that you're
doing throughout your day and your life
i hope that that can shift i feel like i
didn't say my sentence grammatically
correct i don't know where it was going
but i hope that that can shift for you
because there is really so much joy in
finding
purpose within what you're doing in your
life and we can also see that throughout
the blue zones
the next one is mindset like i think
mindset is so key and pivotal and i
want to talk a lot about mindset growth
mindset victor mentality
um to be successful in life not just
through something like finances
or um like status because that is super
superficial when it comes to status but
when it comes to
your own uh mentality within yourself
how you view yourself how you look at
yourself that reflects out into the
world and the way that you are
treating other people and how you treat
yourself inside
really affects your health because the
the the things that you're telling
yourself
matters the story that you tell yourself
and who you are inside and the effect
you're having on the world
has a huge impact on your mental health
and i really want to do more episodes on
this topic
specifically on mental health and victor
mentality in the future that is going to
be coming up so stay tuned for that
um but i feel like that kind of well
that that rounds out what i wanted to
say for this episode today
there's obviously so much more that can
be said to simplify
your life and to create an environment
through
the foods that you're eating and the way
that you're living that's going to help
you thrive
but i feel like we touched on a lot of
the basics and a lot of the foundational
principles
and definitely things that have helped
me immensely
to thrive and to feel my best and to
experience
health and wellness one thing i want to
say as we round out this episode
is to be realistic about your health and
don't be hard on yourself
things are going to come up over the
years there really is no one person that
experiences like perfect health for the
rest of their life no matter who you
think they are
no matter what influencer you see that's
telling you this is the key
there really is going to be people
throughout every type of diet and
lifestyle
no matter how they go through life
there's gonna be things that come up
over the years and to not expect to be
super
human and yeah this isn't meant to say
like after all this oh actually you're
not gonna feel that great because that's
not what i'm saying what i'm saying
is through thriving through healing
through coming through
such great um triumphs in your health to
feel so well
also don't think that just because
something comes up like a little thing
here and there that that must mean that
there's something wrong with you or
something wrong with the way that you're
living
try to be mindful and be conscious and
realistic about
taking into account different types of
things and
um you don't need to jump so quickly to
think that oh it must be this it must be
that because a lot of times you might
look back and be like
actually it was something completely
different i thought it was this but
really i was not
sleeping well or i was not getting
sunshine i was not exercising all these
things
um taking that into account i think is
super helpful and just to not to expect
to be
superhuman and if you're finding this
information overwhelming because
you have so much to change within your
lifestyle that you know will help you
to achieve health and vitality
fret not because it does get easier over
time if you include these daily
practices
little by little it becomes easier and
it doesn't feel so monumental
and it actually simplifies your life so
much when you take
into consideration start living these
foundational simple principles in ways
that we are supposed to thrive
and you know something else i think is
really important is that there's a
stigma
about eating plant-based in particular
but really any diet when you start
eating
more mindfully and consciously and more
healthily and you start to eat more
fruits and vegetables because
before you started eating this way no
one cared about what you ate
they did not care at all never had
anything to say but the moment you go
plant-based or the moment you start
eating fruits and vegetables
in abundance is the moment that
everyone's gonna have all these
questions
or i'll have all these things to say
about why you shouldn't be eating that
way
but really health and this and honestly
this goes with so much more
than just food this goes with lifestyles
as well and the way that you're choosing
to live that might be counter
to the norm of what most people are
living but please
just keep doing you um you will never be
at peace with yourself
and may never and you might actually
miss out on some of the biggest
blessings in your life
including healing if you care so much
about what other people think
and you care about how other people are
viewing you you have to do you
and know that the journey that you're on
is going to help you
um to create vitality and wellness
and feel your best and that's just i
think one of the most important points
is to just go on your journey and keep
doing you
and have balance right like everything
in moderation when it comes to
plant-based eating i don't even think i
really touched on this i know i'm just
ending
right now but i didn't touch that much
on like don't
expecting to don't expect to just be
perfect all the time
what you bring to the majority in your
home versus what you eat out and about
once a once a week or once every two
weeks
is not going to affect your overall
health it's the foundational principles
of what you're eating and the
foundational way that
that you're living through your
lifestyle is that matters the most so
i hope you enjoyed this episode and i
will see you next one
thanks bye